since we're nitpicking this incredible show anyway
why the [ __ ] does morty have a coat hung up on
the wall here does he really have no closet or is
this a trophy from a serial killing rick turns on
a light but the obvious light on the ceiling does
not light up coming from some magical source in a
room with only one switch oh i got a surprise
for you come on hurry up gotta go gotta go you
gotta get out you're tugging me too hard exact
conversation i had with my college girlfriend
during jean-claude van damme night at our local
bdsm film dungeon somehow makes it into the show
look if you want to know what we're up against
here the mother moon is drawn with such care here
that they included the phasing shadow the level
of thought that went into this show is astounding
well played show well played i built it out of
stuff i found in the garage did you though the
trashcan and the flashlight sure but i'm pretty
sure you had to get this high density bubble glass
and these giant screws custom-made where did you
find the giant cylinder base for the spaceship in
the garage it also looks like most of the stuff
that you attach to this thing wouldn't aid in
flying but hinder it why would rick even install
seat belts in the first place does he strike you
as the kind of person while throwing together
a junk-crafted space-time ship in his garage
stops for a second and thinks but first safety
how are these two so close when rick clearly
landed several feet away when he fell out of the
ship opening title spoilers also i know rick and
morty wears its references on its sleeve but this
opening theme song couldn't be more doctor who if
tom baker and david tennant were in a threesome
with the ghost of william hartnell while russell t
davies watched also also intro promises an episode
where morty is a robot and doesn't come through
ever there are two or three other things in
this the intro promises and doesn't deliver
and i'm calling my local adult swim about it why
is this pink liquid or the smith drinking pepto
for breakfast i mean with this family i guess that
might make sense i mean if you told me jerry ends
up mixing it with whiskey and has a fondness for
barbed wire i wouldn't say you were wrong two plus
two jessica hilarious that rick said that school
was exactly this and it happens as soon as morty
gets to school but this isn't the first day is
it what did they get taught in the time leading
up to this you know what i named these my little
mortys do you know what i want you to do with them
rename them honestly this kind of joke deserves
a sin removal but he's dreaming about this so
he's dreaming about jessica showing him her boobs
having her call them her little morty's and then
negging her for it it's like he mastered neil
strauss's the game but is only good at it when
he's dreaming we got we gotta get get the hell
out of here and go take care of business what's
with dirty sanchez always having goop in his mouth
and the constant belching with this level of acid
reflux i'm guessing rick's ulcers are on the verge
of ending his life i'm just saying if we don't
find out in a future episode that the belching
and the mouth splooge is actually caused by an
interdimensional species that lives in his gut
bacteria i'll lose a lot of respect for the show
now if you just stick with me morty we're gonna be
holy crap morning run predator pauses predatoring
prioritizing panic and protagonist punchline past
partaking of perfectly palatable people we're
gonna die first act ends on a cliffhanger for
a commercial break only to return with rick and
morty no longer in danger and the monster gone and
nobody mentioning it again and sure that could be
some sort of comedic point about the worthlessness
of commercial cliffhangers but you think a show
like this might acknowledge it a little bit
just take these shoes morty i convenience
them out of my lab coat of conveniences
these things really bring it all together
you have to turn them on morty sure rick
looks like a total [ __ ] for not telling
morty about turning the shoes on before he fell
into the ravine but morty's kind of an [ __ ] for
being this trusting of rick and deciding to
dive in head first without even a question
morty survives this is he immortal yeah it's a
cartoon i get it but in what alternate universe
can a leg broken in at least three places continue
to stay elevated like this i went into a future
dimension with such advanced medicine that they
had broken legs here i'm at every corner drugstore
nice echoing of the back to the future line
there but what kind of place is it that people
are breaking their legs so much that a broken
leg serum is a viably mass-produced medicine
rick separates this seed but there is somehow a
full seed in each half now knowing this show that
could completely be intentional and is some sort
of paradoxical joke that will be retconned into
a story line in season 42 but the pickens here be
slim so for now i'm gonna need you to take these
seeds into the bathroom and i'm gonna need you to
put them way up inside your butthole morty already
full of grace they'll fall right out of mine
i've done this too many times morty sure rick
is a quasi-evil drunken [ __ ] and an unreliable
character overall but didn't he tell morty what do
you think i can just do it all by myself and now
he's saying he's done this lots of times maybe
rick just wanted to spend time with morty i'll
grant that but i'm taking my sin and going home
come on morty please morty you have to do it
morning man rick says morty at least a hundred
times in this first episode i'm sure it's on
purpose for some sort of comedic effect but damn
the effect wears off quick why didn't you notify
us have you not been getting the messages i've
been leaving with morty's grandfather sure this
principle is dumb but if he's been calling morty's
grandfather and leaving messages that apparently
have been going unheeded for two months wouldn't
you try and call the parents at work isn't
that how you got in contact with them this time
wait is there just an unguarded portal just
lying around at this airport no employees no
other people waiting in line oh look honey it's
our son with albert ein douche i mean dickel the
tesla was right there but sure whatever sure this
background joke is hilarious because it's a towing
company that has a mascot that's a toe with eyes
named toe whose catchphrase is ito which could
both be interpreted as i am doing towing as well
as hello my name is toe but the important thing
to note here is that toes don't bend like that
i didn't know hanging out with you is making me
smarter temporary super intelligence is just
a side effect of the mega seeds dissolving in
your rectal cavity oh really then why did morty
only show super intelligence when you asked him
questions to fool his mom and dad feels rather
convenient but how can i hate this show the synths
don't matter and i needed those seeds real bad not
in this episode you didn't meaning those seeds are
about the mcguffinious thing to ever mack all
over my guppies boy you really got me up against
the wall this time jerry look i'm fine with
the speed at which rick made this smart dog
helmet but he must have already had this thing
built except for like one screw to simply go to
his garage and use a drill for two seconds and
produce a finished product go to the bathroom
not sure how impressive that is he clearly just
flushed the toilet because he didn't have time
to climb on top of it and actually use it geez
rick and the time it took you to make this thing
couldn't you've just you know helped me with
my homework morty would be amazing at tv since
i mean the guy teaches high school method
i didn't take him for an active dreamer
i see someone hasn't seen stand and deliver
that's on you rick summer's phone shows
snuffles very close to jerry but he somehow
ends up two feet away from him when it cuts
to the next shot oh yeah this should play out just
fine you said the same thing equally sarcastically
at our wedding and guess what is it just me or
is the jerry and beth marriage way sadder than it
is funny also sitcom husband constantly does and
says stupid things sitcom wife gets irritated with
them to the point where no one understands how
they would have ever gotten married in the first
place and had kids but somehow they make it work
just barely cliche why would i negotiate with you
because we're both rational adults that don't
want anything bad to happen and because i have
a human shield how is rick able to human shield
mrs pancakes since she was clearly behind mr
goldenfold when all this started golden fold
landed the plane and he's created a mechanical arm
to pluck mrs pancakes out of the air while he lets
us fall into a giant vanilla absurd and funny i
think morty's ability to know exactly what golden
fold did and give a full report of it is what
sells it i'll just go ask her to tell golden fold
not to kill us when she wakes up whoa whoa morty
the trick to incepting is making people think
they came up with the idea oh really then what
was that on the airplane then when you pretended
you were going to blow it up how was that top
notch incepting rick looks like goldenfold has
some predilection so shameful he buries them in
the dreams of the people in his dreams i don't
think goldenfold is nearly that shameless about
his fantasies you remember the first episode
that guy was just standing there while morty
unconsciously grabbed his boobs and he leaned into
it at school looks like some sort of legally safe
knockoff of an 80s horror character with miniature
swords for fingers instead of knives why would he
need to be legally safe rick why would he need to
be legally safe okay fine god damn it this show is
clever and funny and all the things three sends
off it was only with years of selective breeding
and genetic altering that this noble beast was
transformed into man's subservient little buddy
convenient tv's position is convenient there are
my testicles summer first off why is snuffles
terrorizing summer of all people over this
second off as a super genius dog you damn well
know where your testicles went buddy you shall
now call me snowball because my fur is pretty
and white snowball must have gotten this idea when
researching video clips about david duke let's go
where the [ __ ] was this [ __ ] the whole time do
you mean the snuffle snowball meant to go in and
chastise summer over things she wasn't responsible
for hope her parents would wake up and go into a
room to see what the matter was then dramatically
reveal this other dog when the time was right
we're trying to get me to get an a in math so how
is rick planning on getting morty a's in all of
his other classes is he just going to inception
every one of morty's teachers every year of
school inception marathon inception thon he keeps
saying we can run but we can't hide like if the
truth was that we could hide it's not like he'd
be sharing that information with us you know this
is a hilarious rick and morty discussion about
a trope in horror movies that characters never
really think about but i'm wondering why they
can hide when scary terry has been popping out of
nowhere throughout this inception dream sequence
in places where he shouldn't know where they are
hi honey you're home early how was your day i have
a lot of questions about this little life that's
occurring in a dream inside a dream inside a dream
inside a dream but mainly i want to know how these
not krueger's use hand soap get off my back [ __ ]
and septic abuse i love you melissa i love you too
terry why is this boner look while my sinhat
wants to question everything about what's in
this room right now this domestic scene for scary
terry and the claw marks that are everywhere that
suggest a sex life that is better than yours or
mine deserves a sin-off for detail and hilarity
this must be a dream because we just saw this
teacher push open a door with a doorknob on it
makes sense because he ain't turning that doorknob
don't even trip about your pants dog here's a pair
on us full and where exactly did morty get the
pants from because i combined many things that
happened in this episode but morty getting bright
enough to know how to mediate the dream within a
dream world is not one of them these halves don't
belong together [ __ ] that's interesting this is
because you don't give morty smith good grades [
__ ] so i know they're making fun of inception in
this episode but even while they're making fun
of it rick was adhering to inception's rules
about making it seem like the person came up
with the idea on their own so i don't know how
the scary terry rocket suddenly puts the idea of
giving morty better grades into mr goldenfold's
head that makes him think he came up with it i'm
entertained mind you but this seems to be going
against the rules of even an inception spoof
i know one thing for sure i'm giving morty an
a in math that's great but what is the wet mr
golden fold shirt since all he had was a bowl
of wheat thins they just couldn't do this thing
without a dog's playing poker reference could they
well at least i didn't really crap my pants no
no that happened before you went to sleep morty
you're sleeping in your crap right now wait
was that even something that happened i don't
remember morty saying he crapped his pants at
any time in this episode until now like it's
something that we were supposed to be aware of
already sounds like you just wanted to wallow in
a little bit joe it's pretty bad emperor
snowball we're gonna need to do another operation
if snowball snuffles is so smart then clearly he
would know this is rick behind the dog mask i see
dogs walking out of an animal shelter into a war
to some other dimension but is this supposed to be
all dogs or just the ones in rick and morty's
town also this puts the onus on the series to
never show dogs in this world ever again i could
just send holiday inflatables because seriously
how did that become a thing but it's much easier
to send the fact that you put rudolph right in
the middle of your driveway also you shovel an
immaculate path to the sidewalk but only half
of your driveway what are you monsters put it
in the stocking summer or i'm joining facebook
a teenager caring about facebook you're adorable
2013 also facebook is this a mirror at the bottom
of the stairs was the goal to both check your
appearance as well as block traffic in the most
dangerous part of your home okay look i know
the show is going for a quick joke here with
his giant morty melon somehow fitting through that
opening but why does the show go to great detail
with some areas of physics but approach this
one by literally jamming its head of its hole
just hold your breath until the process is over
or your lungs will collapse and then he doesn't
and yet he's fine hey dad where's morty he's busy
yeah great joke and all but even beth should be
a little surprised at the naked near-death bad
santa whose chest her dad currently has a giant
needle jammed into right welcome to anatomy park
roll come warchills the anatomy park train has
only one small entrance exit for a train with
three cars and what the [ __ ] is up with these
stairs with no rails that lead to your certain
doom if you fall i love details like a partner
dust sign for an amusement park inside a human
body and i'm certainly laughing but who is this
sign for the park isn't open yet and doesn't
appear to be close to opening so there are
no customers affected by it and if the park has
been open this whole time we're talking about a
logistical nightmare from the customers getting
shrunk and enlarged at the smith house without
anyone seeing it and figuring out where the hell
homeless reuben is to inject them into his body
reuben's seen some rough years morty don't judge
you don't agree to have a theme park built inside
you if your life's going great why is this saying
not a t-shirt who are you why would this guard be
concerned with anybody who shows up here not like
anyone can illegally trespass into this homeless
person's body unless rick specifically inserts
them it's weird that the security guy here shoots
bullets at diseases instead of like vaccines or
penicillin can we talk about jerry's sweater for
a second the colors in the middle section should
be reversed so that the red sections are green
and look like christmas trees unless of course
these are intentional green arrows pointing down
to an entirely different type of christmas
cheer i watch them sometimes from a chair
and sometimes from a closet almost always dressed
as superman cut ken nearly all human lungs contain
a strain of these bacteria but the scar tissue
keeps them dormant if the scar tissue's already
been tampered with then why did the tuberculosis
wait until germ oliver said something about it to
attack what is that horrible smell must be your
own breath because you're breathing air from
inside your helmet from the attached air supply so
smell really shouldn't be an issue keep your eye
on annie she was written up several times by her
manager at the churro stand later on annie will
say actually i studied dr bloom's work so did
she get written up because she was constantly
in dr bloom's lab learning everything seems like
someone who was allowed to study the work of the
main boss wouldn't be stuck at the turos stand
getting written up for whatever reason this also
seems to indicate that the park was open but i
still haven't gotten a definitive answer on that
rhyming food with good gonorrhea can't see us
if we don't move wait i was wrong i was thinking
t-rex why the [ __ ] would you be thinking of a
goddamn t-rex because of the movie jurassic
park that you're referencing throughout the
episode like dinosaurs and infectious diseases
are in any way related enough to confuse the two
if it works we'll be regular sized in a few
minutes you mean there's a growth ray inside
reuben this guy jokes about ruben not being
in a room with white carpet or upholstery and
good for the show for thinking of the gnarly
aftermath of such a move but seems like in a
world of impossible science they'd have found a
way to escape without the grizzly measure that's
bubonic plague so a couple questions here first
why did you leave it roaming free in your backpack
pocket if you had this plan to sell bubonic
plague to the highest bidder wouldn't you have
a container to put it in second why the hell was
there bubonic plague inside ruben what the hell
i'm sorry does the grandfather really think that
his wife and jacob are going to have sex right
now on the couch while his granddaughter
and her boyfriend make out in the same
room the aristocrats also did these closet
door flaps open individually like this or
even at all would you like to ride the bone
train why are you doing this bit we're going
to die morty would be retorting at tv sins what
the hell is that e coli outbreak is it though
because those are clearly bacteriophage viruses
and e coli is a type of bacteria and not a virus
suck my fat virology expertise rick wads would
this fuse continue being lit while in space my
guess is no but i should probably send myself
or even thinking about it when it comes to an
episode about an amusement park inside of a
homeless man reports from all over the country
have been coming in about what appears to be a
giant naked man over the continental united states
how fast did those reports come in exactly rick
just kicked him out of the spaceship and enlarged
him like three seconds ago i'm pretty sure that
dynamite would have exploded before any news
outlets had the chance to make their detailed
naked guy graphic overlays i guess i'm gonna
have to be that guy and point out that ruben
is now the size of the entire continental us
so his face should be covering way more area
than a city block the nipple hole it's beautiful
agreed but i have to ask why is there even gravity
now that interspace has gone to outer space
what the f when the bone train went off the
rails hepatitis a was looking at it go past
him and crash into this nipple area even
if he jumped to grab the train how would he
have gotten inside and the time it took for the
train to crash it's hepatitis c did we have some
sort of relationship with him i think they're
just like that i think they're just good guys
that's hilarious i'll gladly remove the sin
wouldn't this life as rough picture show
the golf ball actually in the rough rather
than on the green where the hole is actually
i studied dr bloom's work i i i believe
i have the knowledge necessary to
create an entirely new much safer park
jurassic world that's it that's the sin
that's atari 2600 donkey kong sounds coming from
these 2013 devices it's time to upgrade our gadget
noises hollywood this is just sloppy craftsmanship
rick would be excellent at biology sins
also dissecting a rodent with the garage door open
what's with mom so you're saying that she's acting
weird on a good day everyone acts weird in the
world of rick and morty yet still i have to ask
why is rick digging in this rat he knows he's
in a simulation he knows the rat has sloppy
craftsmanship so what is he looking for he
doesn't need more proof celebrating math
also wearing an orange shirt and gray tie with a
yellow sweater interesting peeking into a child's
classroom window as an adult also since rick knows
morty is a simulation why is he going through this
charade at the school rick would immediately be
getting the nigerians to show their hands so he
could plan his escape you know if you tell us i'll
be your girlfriend oh you will seems like a rare
opportunity morty simulation or not so listening
sex from a student for bribing purposes will
always be a sin take a shower with me morty what
at times like these i wonder how the writers begin
their creative process does it start with let's
put child nudity in this one do they have a jar
containing tiny strips of paper with random bull
suggestions aimed at making everyone incredibly
uncomfortable and at the start of their brainstorm
they grab several and slap them together
why is this scene lucky for us they're also really
uncomfortable with nudity i just want to know how
rick knew the location of the school showers in
the first place i go through all the trouble of
animating this split-second peak into the locker
room and not put anything interesting in it at all
something is drawing a lot of processing power
you have more important things to worry about
alien scum these fans aren't cooling the
computers properly they're limping along
sort of teeter-tottering back and forth and before
long your cpus will overheat it's a real problem
trimming your nose hair while driving i'm not sure
that i can ask this question without breaking my
own brain but here goes why is jerry separated
from rick from the start they're both inside the
same simulation and yet the aliens are surprised
that they've got another human they're literally
looking down on a massive simulation with two
simultaneous simulations happening within it
there should be no surprise that jerry's here
at all are the writers hoping to avoid revealing
the twist to us the viewers or the aliens
purposely zooming out on jerry's inner simulation
to rick's inner simulation forgetting what is
real at all are we in the simulation two i broke
my brain keep your hands off your ding-dong it's
the only way we can speak freely because for some
reason the aliens are unable to simply listen
to the conversation they must look and listen
national apple farmers of america welcome to
our ad agency but how would the nigerians know
this much detail about jerry's work day when
they didn't even mean to nab him and on top of
that they only have a simulation operating at 0.5
capacity simple question gentlemen assuming gender
this scene just reminds me that dave ramsey has
forever tainted the beauty that is baker street
king dave ramsey well all is forgiven because
right now i've got an erection the size of an east
coast lighthouse hey i'm going to make love to
my wife how big does jerry think lighthouses are
because i'm not even seeing evidence
that a pup tent has been pitched relax
it's just a bunch of ones and zeroes out there
binary code shaming leaving your car door open is
sex really worth giving someone the opportunity
to steal your car or running the battery down
actually yeah i guess it is but for the
principle of the matter i'm still a synonym
making out with dead skin cells excreted from a
scalp i would definitely be on to the simulation
after seeing this everyone knows yellow pop-tarts
can't jump de-panting a child rather than yourself
pop-tart squarepants moments ago they're running
through an alien spaceship and quite suddenly
they're racing through another planet we don't
care about plutonians we care about why jerry is
here at all moments ago they're running through an
alien spaceship and quite suddenly they're racing
on the moon we don't care about the moon landing
we care about why the plutonians are here at all
man up jerry i may need you to work the
lasers putting jerry in charge of the lasers
doors are closing and time is running out but
the protagonist's spaceship makes it out just
in time cliche oh because shooting at the person
you want to steal information from is a great idea
and yes this is a simulation inside a
simulation inside a simulation but the
darkness of it still matters you simulated
my grandson's genitalia you looked at your
grandson simulated genitalia you win can we go
home now i don't know can you grammar police
sure we do it too but we actually spent five years
at grammar police academy to get our certification
up until now i had to brush off my frustration
with english appearing in the alien spaceship
clearly they have their own language we see it
here and here so when the signs were in english
or the doors were labeled i had to brush it off
that this was a simulation and meant to continue
to deceive rick but now here in this moment
before extinction there is no reason for we did
it to appear on the screens for our benefit also
there is no reason for this mixture to be combined
at the helm of the ship during an office party
when there are plenty of labs up in this ship
also also rick and jerry survive this waggling
your tongue when you really don't need to
i already told you it's not your family sure
but can we talk about what they're trying to
do because not jerry seems to have you well in
his grip and able to kill you easily but is just
standing there waiting for this scene that's just
an excuse to justify a title sequence clip to end
why would this facility as part of its
infrastructure have a button that remotely
controls this ghostbusters style trap that
rick had in his hand isn't that something
he just brought to the adventure you make
a request the me seeks fulfills the request
and then it stops existing rick knowing about
this me seeks box makes so many of his previous
decisions in this show completely unnecessary as
disposable as these beings are why wouldn't he
use them as at least an extra pair of hands
to complete all his adventures with morty
i'm mr macy i want to be popular at school
oh okay this me seek schtick is a brilliant
way to play with the be careful what you wish for
trope but in a world where the genie allows you to
wish for infinite wishes god this show is just
the best this village is terribly poor yet the
giant that lives in the clouds above has untold
treasures jeff bezos also this world not only
happens to have the jack and the beanstalk story
from our earth in its reality but rnm also just
happened to land in the village where he lives
just a reminder that even the most brilliant
shows need some little blue convenience pills
once in a while to keep their stories firmed up
in conclusion a friendship with silly smith is
the most valuable and enriching experience of
your young lives mr meeseeks was able to call
an assembly at summer school just to say great
things about her so that she'd be popular and
it looks like the entire school is on board
with a magical blue whatsit they've never seen
before in his pro summer message also holy hell
what kind of acid trip was the designer of this
basketball court on the key area or free throw
dick as it's more commonly called is completely
out of proportion and reaches almost a half court
which would be fine except the other half of that
chord appears to be more like a third of the chord
and doesn't even seem to have any markings plus
that far hoop which is clearly not retracted and
should be at the standard 10 feet has to be at
least 20 feet off the ground based on the scale
of the bleachers underneath it and speaking of
those bleachers why are they behind the podium
when all the space in front of the podium is
available and how did they even get them there
they clearly don't fold in so did they move this
here in one piece this is a gymnasium of lies
i know jerry is a dim-witted sad sack but wouldn't
shaving two strokes off his golf game suggest that
he's somewhat competent in golf if the guy can't
even hit the ball off the tee then isn't the real
request shave a thousand strokes off his golf game
let me try something why did they bring the mesex
box with them on the golf course do they expect
to need extra mr me seeks during this tutorial can
you help me get two strokes off in jerry's golf
swing but if the miseqs are aware of their own
process and abilities enough to call other musics
to help with what i asked them to do wouldn't that
impact their perspective on their own purpose in
a way that negates my original request i guess
what i'm asking is how many seeks would a miseq
seek if a me seek could seek me a rick and morty
from a spider-verse because i don't know how you
climb a mostly flat surface like that without a
little accidental radioactive spider venom me
seeks don't usually have to exist this long
it's getting weird how does he even know this i've
about had it with the discount blue man group's
existential paradoxes here we are you know walking
down the courthouse steps why would the courthouse
steps lead all the way down to the non-giant world
below wouldn't the steps that the giant court lead
to other places where the giants regularly go
also did everyone else in the courts just stay
inside was the rick and morty trial the undercard
to a much more important trial why did jerry bring
everybody back to the house for his lesson how
are you supposed to learn this inside a living
room was he trying to hit a ball inside his house
was he just trying to swing the club because i'm
pretty sure he succeeded at the second thing but
what do i know tennis confuses me what happened
to beth's new hair she had a new style a minute
ago and now it looks like the old beth why did
you even rope me into this cause he wrote me into
this well him over there he wrote me into this the
cinemasins hiring process well what do you know
look down there looks like some kind of tavern or
something the thirsty step i mean the 12th step
was sitting right there stop fighting just let
this happen holy sh my surrealist sci-fi comedy
show just went super dark the creators have even
said they wanted this scene to reflect the trauma
of assault and not be funny at all but here's my
question is this really the place for it i'm all
for victim sensitivity but seems to me the most
sensitive thing to do would be to not unexpectedly
reference real-life trauma in a place where most
wouldn't be expecting to have to deal with it
these me seeks are never given verbal instructions
are we changing the rules so that they can just
intuit what their purpose is now we heard jerry
leave the house when he told them he seeks at this
point my golf swing is more your problem than mine
and he was wearing the green golf shirt but now
he's in a suit but wait neither jerry nor beth
told the musics where they were going for dinner
so maybe after jerry left he went upstairs to get
dressed and came back down and told the musics
where they were going but why did he clearly go
outside after telling them that there's only one
door in the living room that would open and close
and it goes outside come on rick quick stalling
what do you guys read em and weep rick slow rolls
the stair folk rick rolling at this point i'm
kind of wondering how the thirsty step stays in
business their location is awful and most of its
customers couldn't possibly make it up here easily
so we're just saying hitting a tomato with a metal
shelving bar into a large pot about 10 feet away
is equivalent to improving your golf game two
strokes well okay then jesus i didn't know the
mean seeks had such a huge arsenal did they knock
off a gun store on the way to the restaurant or
did the smiths have a hidden gun room i'm a bit
of a stickler me seeks what about your short games
and yet more proof that the mean seeks get to
decide when their purpose has been fulfilled
meaning they could have bailed at any point
and the entire premise of this episode is
null and void and now that i've been this
much of a pedantic [ __ ] i can disappear
also the literal request was to shave two strokes
off of his game and jerry got more than that by
merely learning how to drive the ball so go
[ __ ] yourself stickler me seeks your job
is technically done jerry look we don't have
a perfect marriage but i'm not going anywhere
define anywhere see you next week everybody
the fourth wall is my least favorite wall
yet i'm sad somehow every time it gets broken the
mysteries of the heart confound us letting jerry
help morty with homework i don't know how many
times i have to say this but if you have the flu
stay home does he mean stay home and don't go
to the dance or stay home and don't go to school
because you shouldn't be at school if you have the
flu and if you're not at school how would you hear
this announcement why is this announcement
also episode of a cartoon from 2014 predicts
how selfish humans are when it comes to protecting
others from a rampaging virus the flu season dance
is about awareness not celebration you don't bring
dead babies to passover well someone's not getting
invited to my passover celebration hey wait a
minute where did jessica's friends go try not
to worry about it morty you're a good kid is he
though in this episode alone he asked rick to help
him essentially roofy jessica so i think a little
more honest parenting is in order jerry what the
[ __ ] is the purple meat on jerry's sandwich
ah well i remember feeling that way about a
young lady named your mom and that's not an urban
diss but it works so much better as an urban diss
in fact that's a pretty epic your mom joke that he
just ruined pink jerry we have ice we have no ice
rick is a dick to carbonated sodas wait a minute
did rick go into the kitchen to get orange juice
does rick seem like the kind of guy who drinks
orange juice without adding the vodka yeah i'm
just going to check on your mom and apparently
leave out the mustard mayo an open orange juice
pitcher and an unstarted sandwich do you want
food poisoning jerry because this is how you get
food poisoning jerry and ants a hair morty i need
one of your hairs this isn't game of thrones my
favorite part of every episode of game of thrones
was when the csi team came in and solved the case
there's a calculator of some sort on the right
side of this love potion making machine here
but when it cuts to the wide shot the calculator
is on the left side of the spout your continuity
errors will be the death of you rick and morty
geez did this brad kid go to the dance in his
usual high school attire just adding a tie that's
actually pretty funny but i'm singing it anyway
not that this is the point but shouldn't brad
already have the flu considering jessica was
already sneezing at school today and he
ran right into her sneeze mist earlier
brad got sick immediately is that how the flu
works how come you're not at this stupid dance
everyone loves so much screw that i don't want
to get sick so wait summer are you saying you're
backing out of our trip to south dakota cartoon
dry humping jessica get a hold of yourself
the flu love potion combo which made brad sick in
second should already be running rampant through
this gym considering it was in the punch and the
air conditioning but it waits until someone scolds
jessica before taking over the entire school still
being proud of a swimming championship nearly a
hundred years later whipped up an antidote it's
based on praying mantis dna they mate once and
then they you know decapitate the partner science
i i basically mix this with a more contagious flu
virus why did you need to mix it with a flu virus
when everybody at school already has the flu
these serums they don't work on anybody related
to you genetically i mean thank god but that
still is a serum of the highest convenience
the only thing that is known is how cute he is
i love him so much i want to make love to
him how did these news anchors even get
to their jobs if they were obsessed morty
loving praying mantis creatures also where
did they get a picture of morty that quickly
that's almost creepier than the love potion
how is this virus already spread to other
countries the news station was hard enough
to buy but at least it was potentially local
and this is going to be an issue for the rest
of the episode so instead of bringing it up
several more times i'll just add 10 cents here
wait so everyone knows where morty lives all of a
sudden what the heck is that a morty doll how did
they manufacture that well i'm glad we saved all
those horses why did you short the glue industry
how did the flu mantis concoction get all the way
out to the horse hospital have people been drive
by sneezing around this place i'm mr crowbar
and this is my friend who is also a crowbar
i can't imagine a world where jerry actually
deserves a sin off but i'm giving him one
regardless if people from other countries are
whiffing the antidote already wouldn't they have
a period of time when they turn back to normal
before morphing into these abominations that's
what happened to everyone else how did this guy's
underwear stay on and intact throughout all these
transformations here's another thing rick made the
love potion for morty using his dna and that's why
his family wasn't affected but he made the mantis
potion in the every animal on earth potion without
morty's dna so why aren't they also turning into
trauma creatures right now hold on mad jerry fury
road mad max jerry road furious jerry maximum
mad max and furious presents rhodes and shaw
the fury is there any reason for beth and jerry
to get out of the car and fight these things
they were doing just fine running over all of them
what's the goal of coming out to purposely kill
these things other than to pad this episode's run
time boy morty i really cronenberg the world up
didn't i don't be so hard on yourself rick the
world doesn't look too much like him butterfly
here morty put this on while i do a little bit
of scouting why does morty need to wear this
thing while rick does his scouting what computer
works just because someone's wearing a backpack
apparatus okay so we're about to find out that
this is one of the infinite realities that
original rick found where a parallel universe
rick was able to get everything back to normal
and the rick and morty we see here are not
the original rick and morty team which is
what the show wants you to think so why is this
universe's rick and morty just now getting back
to the house after a newspaper was published
explaining how everything went back to normal
the answer is don't think about it it's not like
we can do this every week anyways we get three
or four more of these tops yeah but that violates
the cinemasins and therefore tv sins charter where
we were told to think too deeply about it it's too
convenient yes you don't follow the same rules and
you definitely shouldn't because nothing creative
would ever get made but that doesn't mean that
we're not sinning you for this replace the dead
rick and morty in a different universe bit i'd
grown super fond of the original summer beth and
jerry and now i'm gonna have to be cool with exact
replicas with no differences whatsoever you owe
us an apology also you only get three or four more
of these tops has rick ever watched anything on
network television leaving the refrigerator door
open he's got lifeless eyes black eyes like a
doll's eyes glad summer could hopefully write
jaws on this box in case you didn't know the
reference but what happens when she decides to
do the englishman who went up a hill but came down
a mountain not enough room on the box to explain
that reference then why would you need these kind
of lines in a galactic parking lot shouldn't it
just be a series of different sized squares for
vertical landing and takeoff also what's the deal
with these parking lot lights they're illuminating
a building that's already lit up and neglecting
the rest of the parking lot i mean it's different
from the stuff on earth they have sex dolls on
earth and something tells me morty knows way too
much about that aliens on another planet not only
speak perfect english but their stores have open
and closed signs written only in english like what
if you passed away or died or something i wouldn't
even have anything to remember all the cool stuff
we did you know remembering your late grandfather
every time you use your sex robot so we're just
going to pretend this isn't happening well not
with that attitude we aren't rick why would you
let morty bring that thing into our house i mean
we know jerry has no power but why did beth allow
it in the house the real question for rick is
why did you buy that for morty in the first place
really simply drinking from the carton is a sin
but it's doubled when you're drinking from the
carton after having sex with an alien robot sorry
them's the rules intervening with puberty you'll
turn him into ray finds and red dragon first it's
clearly ralph fiennes i mean learn to pronounce
things but also referencing ralph fiennis from red
dragon instead of tom noonan from manhunter just a
few seconds ago morty was robo-railing so hard
he had the downstairs light swinging but these
knickknacks just stay put on his headboard i don't
even know how these stay put when he's not deep
droiding this thing could grow to the size of
delaware pretending like delaware is large or
exists i've gone too many episodes without sending
this and i can't hold back anymore that sock has
never been moved from that spot in the garage and
it drives me absolutely insane every time i see it
my therapist will be thankful i don't have to
discuss that with her anymore portal question 253
if you can't see through the portal how would
this creature know exactly where and how to grab
summer still think it's a good idea
to go through holes without a wiener
dub dub sorry just always wanted to do that so
maybe a sin on me that's fair great now i have
to take over a whole planet because of your stupid
boobs i can't tell if the show is aware and poking
fun at victim blaming or just casually using it
for a laugh and considering the damage that kind
of thinking does every day this is either a sin
for the show's attitude or the idiots who think
this way also watch what you're saying about
boobs mister those things are like universally
beloved he goes tom hanks pizza then boobs and
honestly hanks and pizza better watch their back
why do tv families always store their fruit so
close to the floor also storing bananas with your
other fruit is a terrible idea bananas release a
gas that makes other fruit spoil quicker crap that
was actually somewhat educational um bananas look
like penises saved it your hands bears your hands
title of my sex tape and that's how we play
heavy hands oh you are going to ruin that
kid morty could be worse he could be showing
him caillou what's the opposite of wubble up
a dub dubs am i right ladies and gentlemen
it's bad enough you're breaking the fourth
wall but now you're throwing test questions our
way too i'm tired of zoom classes leave me alone
having a section of a newspaper simply titled news
spider in sector c is still alive plan your route
accordingly and expect delays so this world's
just going to be a bunch of sexist jokes now i
mean admittedly super hilarious sexist jokes like
that restaurant that's called just a bite of yours
the weather report said is
anyone else cold or is it just me
sorry i mean that's racist the females are
placed into educational programs the males
they get to play outside the original
plot outline for boss baby somehow makes
its way into this episode yeah you
know what i have to say about that
rick survives this fart can we talk about these
ear arms for a second we've seen them active so
we know they aren't just vestigial so how does
the musculature work part of the reason you can
control your arms is in the shoulders and chest
and sure maybe they have some thick traps hiding
under that hair but what about the pecs shouldn't
they have some sort of chest muscles where their
cheeks would be and that would mean they would
also have boobs there too six arms should mean six
boobs damn it also do you know how hard it
would be to hold your arms up like that all
day those arms should be dangling down like
flaccid fleshy earrings also also does this
mean if they don't apply deodorant they have
bo right next to their nose this is terrible
design and the god of this universe should be
punished to the maximum extent of celestial law
was this really the time to make that point summer
kids this is for you daddy well i guess we know
where this episode stands on the whole nature
versus nurture debate good news parents what
you do doesn't make a difference only handcuffing
four of the six arms and doing it via two separate
handcuff sets with a foot of chain between
them and in front of the body this does nothing
look at the tag read it where was that tag hiding
and is that really where a tag would be on a top
like this mark jacob these are names of the penis
look a lot of what these alien ladies are saying
about men is very true but we give our penises
way more interesting names than mark or jacob
like boomerang or big rick or count schlongula
if you think my top is cute you cannot execute
johnny cochraning morty junior smoking but where
did he get the cigarettes he hasn't gone outside
no one else in the house is a smoker i don't want
to masturbate i want to conquer the planet oh just
like this generation and not be able to multitask
also this race is so horny they just drop sex
robots on them and then have them all impregnated
within minutes so i think his murder boner would
be accompanied by a well boner boner but first a
deep sip from a very tall glass of i told you so
those are gulps not sips you noisy and biber
running wild running hot show makes fun of
motivating characters with songs and that is just
not acceptable without survivor and robert pepper
rocky would have never been able to beat ivan
drago and don't you forget it also movie steals
the footloose scene from hot rod hey stop that
thinking honking your horn will stop an alien
monster from destroying your car and potentially
killing you i never got that impression from
reading marmaduke joe wants us to believe that
a kid in the 2010s would be reading marmaduke
see you guys next week see everybody next week
this joke literally only works one time the
first time it airs unless you're the kind of fan
that plays your blu-rays or streams weekly to be
more authentic why don't you just prove you're a
better fan than the rest of us by having weekly
viewing parties where you can all quote lines from
the show and sing songs about how great it is and
crap i just invented a religion didn't i i know
animation is tough guys but why is the end table
behind the couch now when it was between them
just a few seconds ago you show us your concept
of good tv and we'll crap all over that tv sim's
mission statement somehow ends up in the script
didn't snowball and the other dogs in this
universe leave in episode two why do the smiths
still have this bed out here sure it could be that
they're just too lazy to get rid of it but after a
quick cut away to jerry it's now gone so that's
a continuity error at least one way and maybe
even two you can probably guess which way i'm
leaning how about showtime extreme in a world
where man evolved from corn welcome to the rick
and morty improv show with all the hits and misses
and improv show entails it'll be just like the
everyday programming on channel 62 in the movie
uhf the fact that this gun was duct taped to his
back and yet the duct tape somehow stays in place
after he grabs it to pop this other coin doesn't
even have a kernel of truth to it what too corny
letterman from a timeline where jerry's famous
they stumble upon shows that directly relate to
themselves on a tv with infinite worlds and
infinite shows and i find that infinitely
convenient no the other thing go back really all
right fine why would the tv go back immediately
to the guy eating when rick changed channels
twice since they ran across this disgusting
[ __ ] this episode is a treasure trove of
quick hilarious visual gags like bottomless
baseballs or a version of game of thrones
where everyone's a little person except tyrion
i've never loved my pause button so much in
my life here these scan your retinas and let
you view parallel timelines and i happen
to be carrying this thing around with me
at all times check out this refrigerator only
200 pretty hilarious that because ants in his
eyes johnson can't see he thinks the dryer is a
refrigerator but did anyone help him shoot the
commercial wouldn't someone correct him that
he's pointing at dryers this commercial isn't
being shot edited and broadcast live although that
would be quite the trick i've heard of fire ants
but are there fireproof ants because those ants
seem just fine despite being engulfed in flames
i don't see anything there's a chance you
weren't even born i thought the headset scanned
your retinas and matched them with your parallel
universe cell so why would the headset go through
parallel universes where summer doesn't exist
also if these goggles also land on realities you
don't exist in they would be rendered basically
unusable with infinitely possible universes the
chances of you landing on one you actually exist
in is infinitesimally small a mexican armada shows
up and their ships are sombreros seems kind of
racist alien invasion tomato monster mexican
armada brothers i felt a great disturbance in
the force as if millions of sins suddenly cried
out in terror and were suddenly silenced it's
called two brothers two brothers it's just called
i don't know what i like best about this episode
but hearing justin roiland laugh at his own bull
might be the most honest and funniest part but
leaving in the laughter of you cracking yourself
up seems a bit distracting and over the fourth
wall line even for this show so know this hurts
me more than it hurts you and i'd be on dicaprio's
yacht banging kristen stewart since these goggles
are directly connected to the dna of the person
watching shouldn't it disconnect once removed
from the scan we just discovered a show called
ball fondlers but you guys clearly backed the
wrong conceptual horse yeah but ball fondlers is
just the a-team could watch regular limited cable
to watch that fakedoors.com is our website this
website doesn't work which seems like a scent
until you realize it is owned by the company that
owns rick and morty so it could be an inside joke
about how just like the doors and the ad don't
open neither does the website or it could be
because this is an alternate universe so the
website wouldn't exist in this one like with
many rick and morty observations i'm left
wondering if it was accidental oversight
or intentional genius but here's a sin anyway
since it made my head do hurty brain thinking
huh he's making himself a sandwich now this top
piece of bread has nothing on it which means he
has put the peanut butter on a slice of bread
and then jellied on top of the peanut butter
one ingredient per slice you monster also he sets
the dirty knife directly on the countertop it can
put up with a lot in this world but people who set
dirty utensils on the counter can go straight to
helmets still here still selling fake doors this
might be one of the funniest things they watch on
infinity tv but what kind of world is it where a
guy who sells fake doors can afford a commercial
that runs 90 seconds or longer paid for by trunk
people man that trunk people emblem seems really
offensive but i guess the trunk people chose
that no room is safe from the turbulent power
of turbulent juice was that a movie or like does
it clean stuff as usual morty would be amazing at
tv sense baby legs you're a good detective but
not good enough because of your baby legs i'm
totally down with a random vibe of infinite
cable possibilities but why would baby legs
wear a diaper is this guy an adult but like a baby
can't control when he goes to the bathroom so i'm
partnering you up with regular legs is everyone
with regular legs named regular legs or does this
guy's leg stand out amongst his peers as the most
regular which would be a contradiction in terms
also this feels like an average everyday weird
cartoon you can already find on cartoon network
it's in the same vein as assy mcgee here we go
that's the sound i make when i'm trying to run
fast this is basically bec bennett's office boss
character and when you're stealing from 2013 snl
you may want to rethink your sketch premises that
out there that's my grave wow those graves are so
freshly dug and moundy that it's pretty incredible
no one from this family has stumbled upon them
these graves are more obvious than the ones
ron perlman sees at the end of the last supper
nobody exists on purpose nobody belongs anywhere
everybody's gonna die come watch tv if 2019 were
a movie this would be the tagline on the poster
2019. mrs sullivan always planned to leave
everything to her cats i understand this
is infinite cable but why does rick somehow
always end up on a movie trailer rather than
simply a movie oh mrs oh sullivan wow this movie
this g-rated what does it need to even get to a
pg not to mention r but i imagine in their world
gasparnoy finds ways to push the envelope i guess
jerry ate someone else's toe because all his toes
are intact in the shot while this reflection
in the bird cage gives us a perfect image of a
sad bet the reflection itself seems completely
impossible given the pov and it doesn't even
appear to reflect the cage itself oh come on as
if the odds weren't astronomical enough that they
would even land on anything about themselves both
jerry and beth happen to land on the same reality
i've never stopped thinking about what might have
been wow a pretty unexpected heartfelt whammy at
the end of this episode full of randomness this
show was so good hey rick i have to make a project
for the science fair this weekend you think
you could help me out science fairs well i mean
traditionally science fairs are a father-son thing
so girls never have to participate in science
fairs that's unfair fair and racist eating
pancakes with butter and no syrup oh my god
a brand new sentient robot would say oh my gears
just saying whatever this guy is doing balancing
plates on thin air i see they fixed the shelf
but they changed the animation so add another sin
i make my own stuff and the animators make their
stuff up on the spot too the skull candle and a
floating elephant carcass are brand new additions
to this counter i'm a man of science and i'm a man
who likes consistency why is the elephant in a
jar over here now not to start a whole another
gif gift debate but does the glue have a label
on it claiming to be sticky giz or jizz but
you know spelled with a g for some reason why do
we have to corrupt glue why does glue have to be
perverted being limber enough to flop your legs on
the floor like this without pulling any ligaments
or dislocating your pelvis jerry was inside the
house and could have walked through this door
to the garage but instead circles outside to the
garage to enter in dramatic fashion is he smart
enough to think about entering for dramatic
flair this aftershave made women want me but
it also made me impotent oh my god how can i not
see this coming because because you're impotent
the serum should counteract the negative effects
injecting someone with your serum without their
explicit consent i like my devil fights to have
a lot more finger zapping and brimstone and a
lot less back and forth slapping so what was the
ironic punishment for buying the vase how does
a scary ghost go along with your theme this vase
helps your flower stay alive but it's also haunted
is a joke that steps on the theme and you're just
being lazy i'm king flippy nips ruler of pluto
we discovered you quite by accident which is
interesting because pluto was also discovered
quite by accident it was when saturn was going in
and out of uranus and then about to hook up with
neptune you really gave it to those guys at nasa
the plutonians abduct jerry so that he can declare
pluto a planet and i'm sure that's amazing for
their egos and all but why do they think jerry has
any sway over the rest of earth didn't they hear
how nasa responded this is what you do when your
b story has nowhere else to go well i'm going
to get the curses removed at curse purge plus
you know the guy on tv and of course rick is
on the television right this second because tv
show has to news position but why she could have
just as easily said you know the store across the
street as we find out that's where it is in just a
second also this tv wasn't even on 20 seconds ago
but how exactly did rick get a store bought up
so fast rick is not the devil he can't just make
a store appear overnight also how is the shopping
district if first in maine had a vacancy also also
how did rick know mr needful was going to this
window at this exact moment the center of pluto
mr smith is made of a substance called plutonium
pluto exposition pluto's position explodocition
pluto goes from planet to asteroid to meteor
and finally a great visual truly but where did
the pluto dust come from his hands were empty
a moment ago oh my god that's the devil summer
i wish this desk was lighter absolutely none
of the wishes summer makes on the monkey's paw
come with any backfiring curses what a waste of
a monkey poor but how would mr needful know this
he was passed out while summer was making her
wishes mr needful how could you even think of
doing something so horrible i'm the devil can
the devil even kill himself if he's the devil it
implies he sort of lives forever right i can take
out the eternity and the padding and then you'll
have some time traveling mittens and at what point
does anyone ask what the cost for the item will be
these items are literally priceless and not in a
good way i just got bored everybody out how jeremy
in cinemas in staff meetings are you telling
me four billion plutonians are wrong can we
worry about that in just a second because who's
going to tell jerry to stop putting scissors up
his nose in a moving vehicle angry crowd suddenly
has rotting food to throw cliche it was a long six
hours but we've overhauled needful things into the
globally compliant web 4.0 e-nominant needful.com
investing in the dot-com business in 2014 when
exactly did jerry's roof get repaired when the
plutonians showed up initially they pulled jerry
and morty through the roof causing a lot of damage
he dumped me summer wipes clumpy mascara drippage
from beneath her eyes with the simple wipe of her
hand i mean that's the most unrealistic thing to
happen in this entire episode repeating a cycle of
violence repetitively so dad guess what tomorrow
is the day you return this horrific tablecloth to
the store or stab it because it's an alien see
it changes patterns it's absolutely an alien
having trouble holding a consistent geometric
pattern honestly this level of paranoia is a
direct result of watching too much rick and morty
trust nothing everything is nothing or something
umbrella paintings but also tomorrow is your one
year anniversary back in our lives celebrating
arbitrary anniversaries because you can i'm
gonna make you flying saucer-shaped pancakes
and yes as another rick points out shortly regular
shaped pancakes are also flying saucer shapes so
this scene is for teasing that you're making
fun shaped pancakes when in fact you are not
beth is a monster considering breakfast is on the
table i think we're meant to believe it's 6 a.m
and there's no way this family has gathered for a
fully prepared meal by 6 [ __ ] a.m nope in this
episode we learned that rick smarty brainwaves
need morty's dummy brainwaves to keep rick
untraceable or some such [ __ ] yet here in the
opening credits he straight up leaves morty to die
so what's that about our son's been abducted you
hate me for buying those coins to be fair jerry
was frozen when morty was abducted and therefore
wouldn't understand the full reason beth is upset
normally jerry deserves the yelling but
not this time beth also coin collections
jeez rick what is this place the citadel of ricks
it's the secret headquarters for the council of
ricks and where's the counseling center for jerry
and beth's considering all ricks have a morty and
all morty's have a jerry and beth who would be
distraught because their sons are missing turn
your boring old morty into a hot fashion statement
this is a ricktastic concept but he can see that
the ricky's trying to sell his goods to has
handcuffs on and is being transported by some
form of authority right how does he expect to
close a deal here exactly it's supposed to be
funny because they have different hair
styles but it's not cliche if his body
was stuffed into the wood chipper starting with
the head then how is the arm still in one piece
yeah so does the scientist formerly known as rick
why isn't he here in handcuffs because he's dead
too it's half cap shaming so as they say in canada
p suit making fun of canadians wait is that a sin
i can't remember ron morty and then our rick and
morty run by many other rick and morties who would
easily attempt to stop them but don't even try
perplexing considering everyone thinks our rick
is a dangerous rick killer but oh well on to the
portal pandemonium i feel like this is a good time
to revisit the how the [ __ ] does the portal
pew pew gun work portion of the program does he
just think of a specific destination or are the
locations random and somehow managed to spew fire
insects and tentacles at the perfect moment the
incredibly convenient timing is simple either way
based on the fact that we only see asses and no
hands what is the purpose of the giant rolls of
toilet paper who would even use them and how are
the rear ends so clean if the ground around them
is covered in feces this is the least subtle
symbolic anal penetration since the ending
of north by northwest yeah i'd like to order one
large person with extra people please white people
no no no black people and hispanic on half racist
pizza yes i'd like to order one large sofa chair
this is a pretty funny running gag but with all
these different worlds it makes me wonder why the
rix looked the same at the council or it was
pizza rick or telephone ricker greasy grandma
rick and we see a hammer morty later so clearly
these types exist i continue to take issue with
the use of portals in this episode and here's why
rick splats out a whole bunch of options the enemy
appears and they say they could have gone into
any one of these we lost them which means they
aren't tracking our rick and morty so how would
they have known to follow them into the farty
mcpoop smith world in the first place i just want
to point out that there appears to be a fruit bowl
on the bottom shelf which is a really dumb place
for fruit and bowls in the combination thereof
anything else yeah more phone sticks please
so they're eating phones just because they
went into a different dimension does not mean
they have a different digestive system bad guys
avoid looking around the room thereby allowing
the good guys to slip away cliche they look
exactly like us so in order to avoid confusion
i'm gonna mark us each with a red x right now
but they're also wearing different clothing so
you could just go with that as the identifier also
there must be additional exits to this restaurant
because a rick and morty straight up escape so
rather than marking x's on foreheads perhaps watch
those doors hey you didn't pay your bill you said
holy chairs are sentient wrong advertising wow so
people need help figuring out what to buy and then
you help them it's a little more complicated
than that it is not also if the other jerry's
think bulk jerry is useless why would he be
brought along for missions in the first place
appears there are more than enough ricks for the
job you're missing my symphony hey i'll take it
over mumford and sons i'm pretty sure the rolling
stones review for that mumford and sons album was
it's the equivalent of listening to a thousand
naked children being tortured so this race might
still be too close to call we will find our peace
in the next world show now asks us to believe that
the captive mortys have had enough time to form a
cult and mine this cave prison for the resources
to create cloaks printed propaganda and a precise
razor to shave their heads the pointy thing isn't
piercing morty any longer and so all the tortured
mortys spend one beautiful second believing they
are freed before realizing they are likely
falling to their death how special owning a
life is rough poster that shows the golf ball on
the green and barely any rough saved your ass all
right morty don't break an arm jerking yourself
off i mean you can't really do that right right
this is the receiver yeah but where's the
transmitter cliffhangers no eye boogers glitters
stalkers let's lose the tude please losing the
tude speaking of disasters dad we are leaving
you in charge yeah but that's kind of on beth
right why would she ever leave rick in charge
of her children or really anything this shitty
garage door falls outwards after the center is
dissolved by alien eels except the hinges weren't
destroyed so this is a sin for the animators not
making a couple of heels dissolve the hinges and
a sin for the writers for forcing the door to fall
in order to kick off the rest of the episode
well we're past the point of no return bridget
fonda shaming using your binder incorrectly or
writing math upside down and backwards on the
back panel of a binder for no reason either
way us in does that say multi-grain legs
i guess they sell peanuts in a box and abbreviate
legumes to legs none of this seems appetizing more
profitable just keep your sci-fi friends
away from my awesome one how about you all
focus and just keep that refrigerator door
closed while you carry on conversations and
then work on your strategic segregation and you
keep your awesome friends away from my canapes
when the canopy tray came out of the fridge
every one of them had a green olive why would
rick remove one just to add it back in dramatic
fashion i love watching [ __ ] i mean like i don't
know if i personally would ever do it [ __ ] how
many people did you invite rick better question
of the many that rick invited how many are going
to want to get downstairs schwifty with summer's
questionably aged peer group looks like the
garage door was instantly fixed i love seeing
aliens and humans hanging out together despite
their differences but how are none of the people
freaking out right now being a morty at a high
school party casually watching a murder meal
knock it off slow mobius if slow mobius didn't
stop using his slo-mo powers until rick said
something why was rick able to speak at a normal
pace running on deck also stealing this [ __ ]
doesn't feel solid objects in his liquid and that
is [ __ ] concerning they weren't the size of ants
they were ice cube size beings summer don't tell
me you're friends with her popular controlling
girl is pretty and demands your normal looking
friend to be sacrificed on the altar of conformity
cliche i just want to find somebody nice and
sweet which somehow prompts morty to show her
a deadly mad scientist garage rather than the toy
collection in his room apparently the garage door
wasn't fixed in now i'm curious about the side
story where the door was dissolved by eels fixed
before the party but then immediately redissolved
tarped taped tacked and held in place by bullsh
house teleports to a different planet that
happens to have oxygen an immediate hook up
to power cliche you see jerry may i show you
something i was lucy not been caught yet the
operation doesn't seem to be that large
and she's wearing a maids outfit no one
has questioned why she's fraternizing with
a guest instead of cleaning or picking up
rick's using a credit card to turn these
crystals into something snortable but what's
with the number on this thing one two three
four one two three four it can't be a show
that revels in the details and then not expect
a nitpicker to examine stuff like this come up
with a plausible number you jerks move to the left
that's the right step to the right that's the left
that somehow everyone knows instantly also
riverdance did it first the floor drops out
to make it easier we're going to get it nice and
steamy in there with with the floor kicked out
well at least you got all this free stuff
equating free stuff is an agreeable result
of being the victim of a sexual assault it's not
a door beth it's debris i don't care just leave it
yeah okay this door can fit in the front seat so
there's no reason it shouldn't be able to fit in
the back of their wagon with a little rearranging
somehow despite the window being down in the ear
piercing volume of her horrible laugh neither of
these [ __ ] hear her explaining your references
since everything came back as it previously was
where did the rest of this gate go pulling down
someone's pants while they are frozen midstep
wouldn't be this easy in reality these pants
would get stuck at the waist and top of the thigh
don't ask me how i know this not using the ramp
for your cart filled with expensive electronics
and yes it is stolen but it's still valuable
not until i hear you say rixxy business
or rick and morty rick not until
why is this boner
jesus grandpa what did you read me this thing
for a very nosy fella kitty cat huh you know what
happens to nosey fellas do you want me to buy
a subscription to the saturday evening post no
not a word not a word not a word now i went into
a future dimension with such advanced medicine
that they had broken legs here i'm at every
corner drugstore i'm sure that in 1985
plutonium is available in every corner
drugstore but in 1955 it's a little hard
to come by he's got some kind of disability
or something is that what you want us to say
i do implausible i know but i like to imagine
that he had sex the night before and now a little
bit of residue is blocking his urethra oh geez dad
you know that's a lot to drop on a kid all at once
oh my god he's trying to tell
us something that is so awesome
sexual hang-ups in the pleasure
chamber are punishable by death
with their heads you will walk when it is
time to walk you got that [ __ ] i'll come
back tomorrow maybe they'll be gone by then you
better get out of here before somebody sees us
introducing smart dogs the first
dogs trained to train humans
mr spicoli you're on dangerous ground here you're
causing a major disturbance on my time are you
saying there's something wrong with my gear get
to the digestive tract he's coughing i'm possessed
here comes the drums oh my god it looks like a
huge pekka wait a word looks like someone private
there's always a bigger fish sigerian
scammers morty the galaxy's most ambitious
least successful con artist that
doesn't make sense we're good streaky
look at that old lady she's
she's walking a cat on a leash
yes see you in 10 minutes i'm gonna
go home and sleep with my wife
and those words on your dick aren't gonna go away
unless you start using topical cream every day
i'm a white boy but my neck is red i
put miracle whip on my wonder bread
well we're back to our roots driving the same
streets my grandfather started on oh the times
were simpler back then weren't they because
people had integrity i looked at the trap ray
you're out of order you're out of order the
whole trial is out of order i've dreamt of
free solo cap for 10 years and every year it just
looked too big you've come to fight as three man
and three men you are what will you do without
freedom buckle up you're your driver is a snail
hey jessica hello peter what's happening i
throw balls far i'm gonna oh yo you know son
you're not a kid anymore oh no i go to health
class dad i already know all this stuff but what
people call love is just a chemical reaction
that compels animals to breed biochemically
no different than eating large quantities of
chocolate there's something special about you
morty you reached out and you touched it by the
heart rip my clothes off and mate with me for life
it's really important in this pose that you arch
your back and keep it flat at the same time you're
you're you're just a little creepy creep person
you're just this penny stealing wannabe criminal
man
so we're just going to pretend
this isn't happening i'm not
saying that's a bad idea just
asking i drive a dodge stratus
i think i hit puberty should i cut the cord
i think it's linguine can't take this anymore
i learned it by watching you i came here
to do two things eat eggs and nothing
and i'm not out of either will you please not
marry me i choose veronica but imagine if he
came back with something actually useful for
the girl and then he came back two minutes later
with some self-respect and some dignity but one
of us is dead corn ah no the corn paul newman's
gonna have my legs broke this is delicious you eat
pieces for breakfast it says you can't eat anymore
definitely tell you what friends if nobody comes
down and buys a car for me the next hour i'm gonna
club this baby seal that's right i'm gonna club
and see i'm gonna make a better deal you know i'll
do it too cause i'm crazy man woman and now trunk
men man you must be out of your mind if you think
i'm gonna get in this dirty ass trunk hi i'm a
trunk person i am not an animal i am a human being
what is my purpose i brought you into this
world a machine that can think and feel
we are laughing i want an apology nay nay i
demand penance you're watching right side of
the bed i'm grayson chisholm take him to
plutonium bay you can't handle the truth
homer i told you this morning no
guns at the dinner table you no no no
and i hate to get all andy rooney about it
but when did bright colored plastic cows
pigs and rabbits get to be art coffee time
you wake up it's time for coffee advertising
wow so people need help figuring out what to
buy and then you help them cheese it's
milk that you chew you know jerry i'm
not gonna tell you that these will increase
in value or even hold their current value
the truth is you bought them because you like
them they have value to you that's what matters
i don't want them to gain
another yard you blitz all night
speaking of disasters dad we are leaving you
in charge ooh someone has a serious face on
it smells like thai food in here have you guys
been [ __ ] every weekend jackson roses have
their titanic experience in this car and
i have to mop it up oh that's not right
i'm still alive but i'm very badly injured
the beacon was activated and rohan will answer